hype for the third entry into the John
wick franchise has been steadily
building over the past few months an
excitement is only going to grow now
that the first reviews for the film are
in the minutes to do Lion Gate lifted
the restriction on reviews for John wick
chapter three Parabellum critics quickly
published their thoughts on the chads2
hell ski directed action ER reviews for
John Luke chapter three Parabellum are
glowing helping prove that the John wick
movie series continues to outdo itself
where other follow-up films fall flat
Joe blows Jimmy O gave Parabellum a
perfect score praising the film for its
inventive action sequences and its
heart-pounding plot which sees our
titular assassin John wick played by
Keanu Reeves trying to outrun those who
want the 14 million dollar bounty on his
head
after he killed a member of the
international criminal group the high
table and John wick chapter 2 Jimmy O
writes this third chapter is one of the
most thrilling flicks you'll find in
theaters so far this year and somehow
they've found new ways to bring men to
their knees the violence is near
operatic capping off one of the best
damn trilogies ever made it's impossible
to remember the last trilogy that worked
nearly as well as John wick aside from
perhaps Lord of the Rings which is
timeless the third film continues to
build the mythology in the most
satisfying of ways it's a ferociously
fast and immensely breathtaking
adrenaline ride of a flick he added that
John wick chapter 3 Parabellum his
quotes certainly in the running for one
of the best films of the year Robert
Coit or a flickering myth was another
critic who stamped Parabellum with an
impeccable five out of five stars he
said of the film put it this way if
George Miller's Mad Max fury road was
the legendary filmmaker showing
youngsters how it's done this is chads2
he'll ski firing back
much like chapter 2 chapter 3 leaves you
begging for more at this point that John
wick movies are becoming a new drug so
go get your fix prepare for more than
war prepare for constant exhilarating
Anarchy Chris nashua T of Entertainment
Weekly had wonderful words for
Parabellum particularly how its action
sequences which are a mainstay in the
franchise were choreographed he also
applauded actresses Halle Berry who
plays an assassin named Sophia and
Angelica Huston who portrays the
director of the high table for giving
performances that add quote a jolt of
unexpected emotional weight to the movie
nasha watching made his feelings about
John wick chapter 3 abundantly clear in
the final lines of his review I don't
mean to give the impression that John
wick 3 is anything grander than a
gorgeously choreographed gratuitously
violent action movie but as gorgeously
choreographed fortuitously violent
action movies go it's high art Uproxx is
my cryin exalted Parabellum as the best
film in the franchise due in large part
to how the movie expands on the series's
existing world and mythology without
ever feeling bogged down or less than
its predecessors like John wick himself
this third chapter feels like a lean
mean fighting machine and yes it's the
best film of the franchise so far even
surpassing the first film there are
moments in John Wayne chapter 3
Parabellum where I thought to myself
well I've never seen that before Chris
Evangelista of / film called Parabellum
a bone cracking horse kicking dog biting
book smashing axe throwing action
masterpiece while fresh fictions
Kourtney Howard described it as an
eye-popping jaw-dropping show-stopping
next chapter that extends the
world-building beautifully whilst
assigning meaningful resonance to the
character driven action USA TODAY's
Brian Truitt was largely impressed with
John with chapter three Parabellum
calling it a solid continuation of the
killer' franchise that makes James Bond
look about as hardcore as Peppa Pig
though he did admit that the supporting
characters like Laurence Fishburne's
Bowery King Asia Kate Dylan's the
adjudicator
and the big bad Tik Tok man played by
Jason Mantzoukas were a little
underdeveloped
he also wrote that the final act was a
bit messy this third movie brings both
the operatic action and intriguing
exposition though misses the greatness
of chapter 2 because of a convoluted
last act and underdeveloped supporting
characters in the wick versa bloody
action usually leads to much more
trouble later as long as that's at the
heart of the series a pretty good
Chapter three still equals insanely
explosive two-fisted exhilaration Alyssa
Wilkinson a box also brought up the
point of John wick chapter three
Parabellum lacking some quotes narrative
intelligence but argued that whatever
the film is missing in that regard it
makes up for in style and visuals should
the John wick universe have a more
coherent mythology should it come up
with some kind of point it wants to make
showed it in other words try to become a
smarter
movies at some point no I don't think so
Oh Parabellum is just as satisfying as
its predecessors and not just because of
the tick-tock man it is not to be clear
a smart or wise movie it's just a really
fun one of course no film is entirely
perfect though the overwhelming majority
of critics applauded for John with
Chapter three so hard that their hands
went numb there was one who wasn't
completely blown away Variety critic
Andrew Barker felt that Parabellum was
difficult to watch in that it features
so much violence and doesn't let up what
do you need Goods lots of guns he did
however give kudos to director chats the
house key and the entire creative team
for making something so visually
masterful on a level of pure crap then
John wick 3 is unquestionably great
action filmmaking certainly the most
technically accomplished of the series
thus far but as masterfully executed as
the action is watching 2 plus hours of
mayhem without any palpable dramatic
stakes or nuance or any emotion at all
say bloodlust offers undeniably
diminishing returns by and large the
reviews speak for themselves people are
picking up what John wick is putting
down in Chapter three if the film's
critical success thus far translates
into big bucks at the box office
perhaps Parabellum won't end up being
the end of the John wick series after
all according to up roxas mike ryan
Parabellum doesn't really try to play
coy about a fourth movie decide for
yourself if John wick chapter 3
Parabellum gets your blood pumping when
the film hits theatres May 17th check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about John
Waker coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]